[Music]
you see I'm something of a magician
inventor and chocolate maker so quiet up
and listen down nope scratch that
reverse it congratulations on the movie
loved it loved it loved iten it four
times already one thing that four times
yes one thing that is as sure as sugar
you Timothy every film that I have seen
you in you have such a natural way on
camera where you don't see the acting
thank you very understated very natural
very few actors can do that this was the
total opposite it required something
very different of you singing dancing
something more outwards what was that
adjustment like for you in becoming
Wonka it was a tonal adjustment because
um the movies I've been in even
something like Dune that's 8,000 years
in the future they have a very
naturalistic quality and this was very
much like old school storytelling sort
of like golden age of of musical MGM
musical as you put it before so that was
a shift you know um and a sort of like a
stamina U adjustment to always be on you
know um because the character as opposed
to Wily Wonka and the Tim Burton version
and the Gene Wilder version who's sort
of intaking what's what's going on I
think in the Gene Wilder version he
shows up maybe 30 45 minutes into the
movie this is really like the Willy won
is the uh he's propelling his own story
here cuz it's a it's a different story
uh so it was a new challenge yeah yeah
let it all your inhibitions have to go
in absolutely which sort of felt like um
even when I remember seeing uh Daniel de
Lewis at a Lincoln Q&A in high school
and he said uh how important failure is
letting him go and that always stuck
with me cuz he's probably the goat he is
the goat yeah and so definitely having
to let go of inhibitions here and then I
shouted do a sequel it was the greatest
I'm going to show that to you at the end
of
this that that was the greatest that was
one of my top high school moments oh my
gosh a sequel to Lincoln well from goats
to Gods cuz I don't know if you're aware
of this but Timothy called you an
athletic comedy God did you call those
exact words oh my goodness
so I want to know from you because this
you've done theater you've done
obviously you have your comedy Roots I
want to know for you this was almost
like a balance in a sense right like
sketch comedy CU there was so much
there's like one shot of you through a
keyhole where I'm like the facial
expression alone comedy God so creating
this cop I want to know how you did that
first of all to be quite honest a lot of
it was done for me through that amazing
hair and makeup team and the amazing
wardrobe team they they were
unbelievable they they were like half of
it so they were I was putting the
character on it was a lot it was very
outside in and um there was some inside
out elements as well like the dialect so
I I got to really hide in a character
which was really fun I I don't always
get to do that sometimes it's just you
know sometimes you're in a movie and
it's just it's just a version of you
whereas here I felt that I got to I got
to really hide in inside of something
and that and that was what propelled the
character forward it was really great it
was so much fun through the whole movie
in my brain the first time I watched it
I was like please sing Pure Imagination
please sing it please sing it I'm
wondering for you what was the process
of recording that like it was it was
different than the other songs the other
songs were really pre-recorded at Abby
Road which was a trip in and of itself
the beginning half of Pure Imagination
was live you know uh which was a huge
help because uh you know James Taylor
our musical supervisor he was there with
the piano and had a little earpiece that
was playing but there was no rhythm I to
stay within in fact I don't know how
they'll do it on the on the soundtrack
or whatever but it's not it wasn't in
Rhythm when I did he has to come with me
and then you know it could take the
Beats necessary seeing noodle walk away
and you know um I totally butchered it
there but uh that was the that was the
scariest one to tackle but the rest of
it when he's no spoilers once he's
gallivanting with the oal Loompa that
was all pre-recorded in the role that he
was born to play by the way the role he
was born to play um I talked to Paul and
Paul told me cuz I said you've left a
lot of room in between cuz it's 25 years
between the end of this film and the
next one and he told me he wants to take
you so dark in the next one would that
be interesting to you obviously you're
not doing a you're not confirming you're
doing it sequel but you think that would
be interesting play that part of
something happens and you know the sort
of family and friend screenings we we've
had her that Keegan has set up that's my
favorite sort of um kind of conclusion
from this movie because I had that
thought too finishing the script cuz
he's such a joyful character we don't
really get the seeds of his you know you
lose Charlie like that that that quality
so something happens I'm curious about
it I don't I don't know if Paul knows
Paul King knows but uh what happened to
this young young man that you know
curdles his spirits would that be
something you would want to do yeah I'd
be so curious what that story is could
be anything it could be anything it
could yeah it could go in so many
different directions yeah yeah I have
something real quick for you because
I've heard you in other interviews I've
watched every interview you guys have
done for this what is your favorite
chocolate my favor that's a huge gift C
forut that's crazy I'm Canadian are you
kidding me Canan Nikki and because if
you have nut allerg allergy no I don't I
brought one for you too try it oh my God
I mean you got me a fruit N I got your a
fruit n by the way you can buy them in
the United States I don't live there
anymore so you can you can get them here
you can get them here but I wanted you
to know and have it cuz I heard you
talking about it so that's so oh thank
you every good thing in this world
started with a
dream so you hold on to
yours here we go Mama this is such a
wonderful film and I I think we all will
go into this film with the outside world
sort of the influences positive negative
and I know the exact moment where I
completely abandoned myself and gave
over to the joy of this film because
there's not a cynical bone in this
film's body so I'm wondering for you
you've also made these wonderful
Paddington movies what is it about you
that you want to make movies of pure joy
and and just complete innocence because
you're you're taking a Wonka story and
you've made it something totally new oh
well thank you very much I mean for me
the I I love going into to when I watch
a movie to go to feel like a fallen into
another world or another place and it's
a great opportunity in that dark room
just to feel the Troubles of the world
melt away and go go into a different
place so something that can transport
you especially a family movie I think
which you might be seeing with parents
or grandparents or kids and uh to have
to go on a journey together is just the
most special thing you make movies that
are so positive I mean I love Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory and and and
obviously the the Willy wonu meeting
that is very you're not quite sure who
he is and he's very enigmatic and a bit
sort of unknowable and then at the end
there's this moment where you realize uh
that he's the whole purpose is to give
his life's work away to a child and it's
the extraordinary act of kindness and
generosity and that's why I'm a
blubbering wreck when I watch you know
watch the movie or read the book and
when I read it again as a grown up I was
in pieces in a way I think as a kid I
responded to the Vivid colors and the
umpalumpas and all the kind of the bells
and whistles but there's such a strong
heart at the the to it and uh for me
that's the the best sort of movie Q
Grant this is the role he was born to
play forget nodding Hill yes this is
he's finally found something he finally
found but this is my favorite role he
has ever done oh good yes good I want to
know though obviously he's not OA size I
want to know on the day cuz you were the
person there on the day and you know
what all that looked like cuz he sort of
alluded to the fact that there were dots
on his head and what did Hugh Grant what
was his performance like before it was
put into the film what did it look like
well he was on set with Timothy so
obviously yeah so he's obviously not 18
in high which is the one drawback he's
so funny and he's so good at being sort
of sarcastic and and sort of mean kinly
sort of figure and when I was reading
the the the poems in the book I just
kept having his voice in my head and
then once you've imagined him this high
with you know orange skin and green hair
there's no getting it out of your head
it traumatizes you it's a deeply
traumatic image I can imagine there was
a lot left on The Cutting Room floor um
yeah you've you made with Paddington
probably the greatest sequel of all time
and I know you're not going to answer
whether or not you planned on making a
sequel but I feel like there's so much
room between the 25 years and where we
leave off is it something you would like
to do and if so have you already sort of
mapped it out in your head we really
wanted to make a movie with the
beginning middle and end cuz I find it
so frustrating when you've sat in a cema
for two hours and then they go we'll see
you next year and you go that wasn't the
deal I made coming in and uh it's so
hopefully our movie does that and works
on its own terms but we also didn't want
to take him all the way to the Chocolate
Factory and this kind of slightly broken
strange Soul because it didn't feel like
that would be a particularly happy end
to a movie and uh so there's there's
loads of material in that D wrote and in
in the books and the movies of like
things that happened to him in the
middle so I think think absolutely there
could be a sequel but it relies on many
millions of people seeing the movie so
fingers cross you could change her life
this or change all their
lives run away I've watched this movie
four times already I love it so much you
guys look amazing you are amazing in the
film I'm going to start with you Kayla
um I I haven't heard you talk about how
you got cast like how long a process was
this was it a Timothy shalam chemist his
read was that involved I actually never
auditioned with anybody from the cast I
never did I only I did a director
session with the director but um I did
four auditions including a screen test
and I think by like the third audition
is when I actually realized it was for
Willy Wonka so I I got like I did two
auditions just regular self tapes cuz
this was during Co I think yeah it was
during Co and then um I was at um
Universal Studios when I realized that I
was going to England to do a screen test
for the movie and so I got there did the
screen test and all that and I got to
sing and dance and um and act and do
different scenes on set but then after
that I um met Timmy on zoom and he was
filming another another movie during
that time so I met him on zoom and we
talked and then and then I got the movie
um that was um that was in my room with
my mom and we were sitting in there and
the director called me himself and he
was like so I think that I mean like I
would love for you to come back to
England and all that stuff and then I
was like so does this mean we coming
back for another screen test or
something and he was like no you got the
part and we just scream to the top of my
lungs and all that oh my gosh well this
is and this is kind of for the both of
you but I feel like there has to be a
point when you film this movie where you
just have to turn yourself over and
abandon yourself because there's a lot
of performances where you have to be
smaller or you have to be more contained
I'm thinking of your character from
White loce she was very contained and
you wanted to burst but can you talk
about the actual process of filming
those musical numbers and how how much
do you sort of have to just like be not
self-conscious and just let it all go
well I think 100% of like any actor's
approach is to lose yourself in the
character but what helped with this
particular film more than most it's the
realistic sets I mean when you walked on
set it was a city that they had built
and so there's nothing that can make you
forget about you know your you know
actor's apartment and like you know the
your emails than walking into a world
from a different time and it really
allows you to escape into that you know
that the space and the character yeah
cuz I know the moment and I told Paul
this the moment in this film where I I
abandoned myself like you forgot about
everything that you were thinking about
before um I kept thinking to myself as I
was watching a couple of your scenes you
must have been on wires at some point
yes I was on wires I was on wires I was
on wires when I was um on top of the
ladder and I was also on wires when we
were doing the big balloon scene flew up
into the to the air but most of that was
done in green screen but there was one
scene at the very endend when we're like
coming down at the end and then we start
dancing that was real we were like at
least 60 feet high in the air and we
like came all the way down and then we
had to start dancing on wires and all
that yeah wild wow it was fun though it
was so fun what was for each of you the
moment where you would say this was my
most joyous moment on set oh my goodness
we had so much fun the scrub it and
bleacher gang um that song's stuck in my
head scrub scrub scrub stuck in my head
until 2024 that's where we have a text
message thread called scrub Scrub but it
was just so fun I mean I just remember
we were waiting in between takes and all
the actors were there and Olivia Coleman
had us playing this like word game and
it was just the people like for me it's
not just one moment it was just being
around some just amazing people that
understood what we were trying to
accomplish what was your favorite song
to sing ooh to sing like in the film or
just to sing in general like well you
can do both if I mean like um I feel
like a world of your own is probably my
favorite song in the whole film I mean
like it's at the peak of when he gets
his shop and all of that and he's
enjoying himself so yeah that's probably
my favorite song and I got to sing at
that in that just a little bit at the
end real quick who's more evil Mrs
scrubb it or Jennifer kage's character
from White oh boy I think they have to
be first
cousins it's in the DNA it's in the DNA
but they're both beautifully wonderfully
EV and so not like that in real no
that's why it's amazing it's their
antithetical
yeah